CDC today released a long-awaited seven
years study they've been studying this
problem for seven years and they proved
once and for all that the medical
benefits of circumcision outweigh the
risks that's right there's the decision
right there and they recommend that
everybody be circumcised that they get
the procedure done Wow
yeah well at this show we're all about
public service that's why just before we
taped we asked every male member of our
studio audience if he had in fact been
circumcised one gentleman said no so for
him christmas is coming early get him
guys
[Applause]
what are the chances if this
[Applause]
there he goes there he goes on his way
to a better life yeah just really
unbelievable odds doctor the
anesthesiologist is not here yet I'm
sorry we can't wait okay we'll just take
care of that anyway been circumcised is
you a cut above the rest with your
foreskin on the floor dr. Annie knew
just what to do
then we fixed your penis stuff plus
you're an honorary Jew
sopping wet and circumcised
[Applause]
[Music]
that's an old standard actually I love
that song Sinatra did that alright
you